but anyway more to the point one thing i
find really interesting is they
mentioned that
joe biden has lost touch with the
working class and considering this is
like a union area i thought it was
really interesting
because there's that video of joe biden
in the in the factory
and that union worker comes up to him
and he's like you want to take my guns
away and joe biden just insults him yeah
do you remember what biden
what did he say to him that was where he
said look fat was no no no that wasn't
the look fat moment
okay the look fat was when like an older
fatter guy was like joe and then he was
like look fat
oh he called him like a damn liar yes i
think that's what happened
that's the one i think yeah and i was
like are you serious he want this guy
wants to vote for you he just has a
question about your policy and you're
calling him a liar
joe biden calls joe biden tells his own
voters not to vote for him yeah
more than one occasion yeah so uh to be
fair i want to show you this
and i want to make i want to make this
point this is a website called defending
democracy
together.org oh boy they say you know
blah blah blah they don't like trump
donald trump is imperative they get all
these reasons for why they don't like
trump i get it i get it i'm not going to
read it you know why
all of these people are you know former
homeland security
secretary of state nsc staff cia
nsa ooh trade rep nsc
a lot of uh intelligence agency people
and former republicans
and i i just i'm i'm you know somebody
sent me this i posted the the
what was it what he's a former okay so
one of these guys is a former senior
director for n
n o n s c okay i thought it said nbc no
no
we got news yeah national security
national security council that's what i
figured
yeah so i posted the thing about the the
iron range yeah and i think it's a huge
deal that democrats are straight up
being like trump is helping us these are
union guys
because we've heard a lot of the same
things especially from people like sean
parnell
someone countered by posting this saying
oh yeah look at these people
and i'm like yeah you can have them
seriously
keep it so uh the swamp is angry at
trump
good and the union workers in the middle
of this country are thanking him
is that a hard choice no that's great i
think that's perfect and i think it's
perfectly indicative of what he's been
doing the swamp doesn't like him
but normal people do i don't understand
what's happened
how was it how was it the democratic
voter base has become so
unhinged and blind to this so so so
anyway like
i i kind of remember the point i was
trying to make before when i was talking
about kyle rittenhouse
is that people seem to think you know
when i post these things
they're they're saying things like you
know the majority of this country
doesn't agree with you and this guy's a
terrorist
and you know everybody wants trump out
and i'm like
do you do you read the news or is it
just memes
because on facebook it's dominated every
day by ben shapiro
and you know daily wire and fox news it
is memes and i'm sorry i'm
curious of some of the reason that
i think the reason that democrats did
not tune into the rnc was because they
know that they can just wait until
tomorrow morning and they'll just hear
exactly what they want to hear from
people like yamiche
and everybody from pbs and they'll get
everything they want through their own
filter of their own little bubble they
don't have to hear anything they don't
want to hear they don't have to actually
listen to donald trump
speak which let him probably trigger i
mean you know i so i jokingly have been
posting things like
trump landslide so so the first thing i
post on facebook is that benny johnson
clip where you get these c-span callers
nine minutes i swear i'm like i gotta
listen to it it's my job
it's great i'm sitting there i know and
i'm clapping and laughing there's like
ladies it's it's kind of crazy to hear
like just this middle-aged woman being
like
the riots are near my house the
democrats won't talk about it
and i'm imagining just like my hokie old
neighbor like they don't pay attention
they're normies they mind their own
business and they're scared right now
yeah and the democrats praised the
protests
who was it who said that i think it was
um i think i actually have it right here
yeah yeah check it out
the atlantic this is how biden loses
nothing will harm a campaign like the
wishful thinking fearful hesitation
or sheer complacency that fails to
address what voters plainly see
oh boy i mean they look at this they uh
let me just read the paragraph they say
it's no use dismissing their words as
partisan talking points in reference to
trump's law order
they are effective ones backed up by
certain facts trump will bang this
loudly
ugly drum until election day he knows
that kenosha has
placed democrats in a trap they've
embraced the protests
and the causes that drive them the third
night of the democratic convention was
consumed with the language and imagery
of protest
as if all americans watching were
activists
the point written here by the atlantic
this is how joe biden loses
the iron range a democrat stronghold
has six cities from the iron range not
not the entirety of
has endorsed donald trump we also heard
the story from cnn a little while ago
they went to like the northern tip which
is probably a similar er like you know
probably in the iron range
and they found they said it's a democrat
stronghold that supports democrats
locally
and votes donald trump nationally yes
and they're all proud of it
yeah they don't mind so i have to
imagine this
uh actually let me let me give you some
context first michael tracy
who is one of the few journalists who
actually exists
albeit he's very snarky on twitter when
he talks about you know politics but
he actually got in a car and he drove to
small towns
and he saw the destruction and he saw
many of these people
doing what i would call begging spray
painting on their windows like police
don't hurt us we support black lives
matter
he went to towns that no one that
that got no coverage that nobody even
probably knew
had riots until he went there now
imagine this
you live in some of these towns they're
democrat towns and you turn on the tv
and you tune in to the dnc and what do
they do they show
the protesters they show them raising
their fist
and you think to yourself aren't those
the people that just smashed up my
windows that i'm scared of
yep i'd bet yep and and they're getting
spotlight and not you
and well it's the democrats supporting
them yeah and now it's it's blowing up
in their faces and they know it
and that's why the atlantic has this
article check this out
they say on monday the day after blake's
shooting biden and his vice presidential
nominee senator kamala harris released
statements expressing outrage
the next day biden's spokesperson
released a statement opposing burning
down communities and needless
destruction
and on wednesday biden after speaking
with the blake family condemned both the
initial incident
and the subsequent destruction burning
down community communities is not
protest
he pleaded in a video it's needless
violence he said the same after george
floyd's killing
how many americans have heard him in the
crude terms of a presidential campaign
voters know the democrat means means it
when he denounces police brutality but
less so when he denounces riots
to reach the public and convince it
otherwise biden has to go beyond
boilerplate and make it personal
memorable i don't buy it no you know why
i don't buy it when he says well the
destruction is
bad because then the dnc puts up the
videos the guy with the cape you know
like that remember you guys see that
thing where like actually it's that
tweet that i put up like
billy porter i'm going to try to find it
so it's this guy dancing and he was like
it was the cringiest thing i'd ever seen
it really did look like a high school
town i got it here we go oh look this is
this image
of the protests and this guy with the
cape singing this protest song
and this person said we're going to lose
aren't we i love this this image because
it's like
yes i'd imagine you are but this protest
image
listen if you've got a bunch of people
marching through the streets
raising their fists like he is right
here screaming black lives matter
while smashing things and the democrats
go on go on tv and with a smile on their
face go peaceful protests
and you're like they they smashed up the
bakery by my house
yeah or not even that you know when they
talk about smashing up starbucks and
they talk about smashing up banks i'm
like did you ever stop to think about
what the average person feels or thinks
to themself
when they see that so i was i was in dc
on uh
they call it j20 it was trump's
inauguration in 2017.
they smashed up mcdonald's and starbucks
and like some banks or whatever
and i was talking to somebody cause i
tell them this all the time you ever
stop and think about what that you know
a regular person
who shops there is thinking once they
walk up can't go there anymore they're
thinking why can't i go to starbucks i
got work i need coffee
why can't i go to my bank why can't i
deposit my paycheck
and now i'll one-up that i said do you
ever stop and think about what the
person who worked at starbucks is
thinking after you do that
no i can't work why did they do this to
me that's what they're thinking
why me why me what about the person
working at the bank
i was talking to somebody during occupy
wall street i'm like do you know how
much that person makes
in that in that small little office
they're probably making like 40 or 50 oh
it's new york so maybe like 60 70 k
all right that is not middle class
median for new york they're probably
working really really hard to try and
get by because new york city is very
expensive
i understand in most parts of the
country 70k's probably a lot but some of
these people in these offices probably
only getting like 50
if that and i said juniper thinking now
that you smashed the window there's
glass all over their desk and their
computer
they're thinking what did i do i don't
understand and the people who go to that
bank as customers are thinking like i
gotta i gotta make deposits today
right i gotta i gotta i gotta get a
cashier's check to pay for my my deposit
for my new apartment why did they do
this to me
now i got to go to a different bank how
how frustrating is that
and they don't understand why they are
being attacked now imagine this
you're in a small town you know you're
like remember that video from i think it
was like
was it was it rochester or syracuse
where the lady gets attacked by the
group of those that
those men you know i'm talking about the
husband and the lady of the fire the
fire department equipment store
and there's like three dudes attacking
yeah so imagine that
you're in a small town you're minding
your own business the news doesn't talk
about you
the new york times doesn't talk about
you cbs cnn they don't care about you
you're in a small town and you're being
beaten
and your wife is being beaten yeah and
then you're just angry and you're like
someone's gotta do something about this
mayors know where to be democratic
mayors nor to be found governors
saying peaceful protest then you turn on
them you turn on the dnc
and what do they do they show the people
who attacked you
yeah man i'd be i'd be angry i would too
and you know what i would do
i would call c-span i'd be like hey
guess what i'm leaving the democratic
party they've moved way far left i just
watched the uh
the dnc and i'm they're full of nonsense
and i don't like it i'm scared
i do what i'm doing now yeah you know
it's funny because i've talked about
this
you know several times when the riots
hit their peak in june i heard
helicopters and sirens
i remember that i heard them too we're
in the suburbs i was like there's no way
no way because we're like we're in the
suburbs of the philadelphia area but
we're on the jersey side you got to
cross the river
and i'm like we're far away you know
but no it was it was within a few miles
we could see we could see and hear the
helicopters and sirens
and i was like how did they get anywhere
near
us that's crazy that was an
uncomfortable night
and then i went out and bought guns yes
because i was like what do i do if they
show up to my house
because they've shown up to people's
people's houses thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you